kappa outdated pogchamp overrated long
have you waited now we debated oh it's
about time no matter what game you play
you've seen a bait you've seen one
player outmaneuver or trick another with
a strategy they didn't see coming and
even outside the game you've definitely
fooled one of your friends into doing
something really stupid
oh yes donations flooding in for skin
tim donated ten dollars he says shadow
line all my young samus means you fell
for the oldest tree the one dollar
donation from jet it's cool twitch users
have a simple word for the feeling of
euphoria you get after making your
opponent or friend look like a giant
idiot jebaited the face itself belongs
to fighting game tournament organizer
Alex Joe Bailey who runs dream hacks
fighting game events and founded the CEO
tournament series CEOs are best known
for their top eight wrestling ring stage
and the incredible entrances it inspires
[Applause]
[Music]
what you baited wasn't always the
manifestation of prankster joy that it
is today
it was once a completely different face
the face of legendary 90s wrestler slim
jim evangelist
and human personification of cocaine and
steroids Macho Man Randy Savage there is
no one that does it better than the
Macho Man Randy Savage
in 2011 G Bailey happened to be friends
with Ben fishsticks goldhaber one of the
earliest employees of twitch TV and
fishsticks decided to give Joe Bailey a
global emote it was a picture I just
taken a me just standing like a random
swagger position with a microphone at
the famous CEO 2011 the very first one
in the new hotel and somebody put a
Macho Man Randy Savage picture next to
and they're like holy [ __ ] like I was in
the exact same pose as him not even
knowing and so boss logic saw that you
put a beard and glasses on me back then
I was friends with fishsticks he was one
of the first guys to support the FTC and
he's like hey you know his CEOs growing
in popularity you know I work at which
would you like to just you know be an
emo with that jebaited fishery picture
he looks like a funny picture me yeah
sure why not
and so the Macho Man emote stuck but it
was known as jebaited the word jebaited
itself was coined by the fgc
specifically Joe Bailey's local
community because of a habit he had of
unmapped buttons on his fight stick and
then pressing them to confuse opponents
who were listening too carefully and I
used to have an empty bun where I would
hold back with balrog charge and then
press forward and hit the empty bun so
my opponent would think I was doing a
dash punch they would do something I
would punish it with ultra and one guy's
like ha you got jebaited and that's
where the word kind of took off from
there but it wasn't really being used to
describe that pranksters high of seeing
someone get baited at least not until
2016 when twitch came knocking again
five six years later switch had hit me
up like hey we're future proofing all
our global emotes for 4k and tablets and
everything do you have a higher res
image of that photo and I'm like uh
probably not let me go ask my guy
and boss I was like dude I threw that
it's either that years ago so he
couldn't find anything and they're like
well yeah if you don't have it we'll
just take it off like no Rick from combo
breaker you know my branding manager we
were just like looking through all the
CEO pictures I had and just like what
looks like my face you know that's
recognizable and stuff so we saw just a
bunch of them and that picture was taken
when I was watching Kenny Omega and
Xavier woods which was a total surprise
Kenny was there but Xavier what's
showing it was the total surprise we've
been working on
it's like sneaking to the hotel and all
that and have him like appear on the
stream and then they started playing
their little Street Fighter 5 exhibition
which went viral is huge and Robert Paul
took a picture I mean just in the right
moment where I'm just looking up at the
screen watching and the crowd just going
nuts I'm just thinking to myself like
yeah we did this you know like how
awesome was not happy I was thus the new
jebaited was born not a macho man like
to take all the candy and pour it on
your head right now
but of a different also insane wrestler
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it didn't take long for people to notice
it either within a few days of the
updated jebaited emote appearing on
twitch someone developed the now iconic
long have we waited copypasta which
spread like wildfire two weeks later it
was like League of Legends worlds at the
time and somebody created that copypasta
and man it just took off to 400,000
viewers in the League of Legends chat
and I'm an fgc chat and it just blew up
from there and then everyone's like
Jesus to Bailey's in the League of
Legends world chat and then just it
escalated min and then it just goes over
and now I still get messages like oh
streaming everyone kept saying debate in
the chat I hate you you know people are
saying the word at schools and stuff I
have friends that I hire for some of the
events I work like Dreamhack and like
yeah I'm a teacher and a kid set it
randomly to another kid like how you got
your band he's just like god I have to
think about your billion work to the
named your bated goes almost perfectly
with the emote baiting someone is a joy
especially if they fell for something
obvious whether it's in-game [ __ ] you
baited oh my god I can't believe it
or out to summarize a sporty guy a job
date of the prom queen do you ever
wonder what she's doing now you could if
you saw her you could catch up yeah yeah
I mean we are just here for the show and
wouldn't it be amazing
if she was here
what
[Applause]
she's not here we didn't it's easy to
understand why its popularity spread so
quickly jebaited is way more fun to say
than baited them they're gonna kill
Geoff's fanatic this is what they get
for trusting them oh let's try to escape
they get three kills Dancy and let's be
honest that thrill you feel when you
make someone look like an idiot there
had to be a special face for that dude
that was all the what I have left to
repair that it's fault you get you gonna
get it there you go man are you gonna
get it over the years Joe Bailey has put
his face on a lot of things he's
essentially become the mascot of his own
tournament series his reputation for
brand building even got him a spot in
the indie fighting game dive cake as
Jeff Ailey a character whose head got
bigger every time he won after such a
sudden rise to prominence you'd expect
jebaited to go to Jubilees head but it
hasn't III scene is just personal
branding that people always relate it to
the FCC but the people that don't know
me using it I think it's awesome and
then I hear stories of like somebody
uses the word like you don't even know
who the guy is like who and then they
like tell like oh my god that that's
actually a person like what does he like
and stuff like that so but it brings up
conversations that get people thinking
about what the FCC is that said he has
very much leaned into it he takes
pictures with just about everyone doing
the face and pose even the Daytona Chief
of Police it hasn't necessarily changed
his life though it has led to some weird
situations Pokemon World Finals I was at
us I was the tournament organizer for
Vulcan tournament and some I had on my
laptop the jebaited picture and I didn't
hear them but they were like
international and they walked by like
four girls like oh my god that's the
traded picture or whatever and I'm
sitting right in front of it and they
don't even and somebody like walk down
like you know that's the guy like no way
we like to take a picture and stuff it
was funny
while jebaited isn't necessarily the
most popular emote on twitch it is in
the top 50 and a lot of the time you'll
see people post walls and pogchamp
between the jebaited but really that's
just inefficient memeing the joy of law
and the elation of pogchamp combined
make up the glorious gratification of
feeling smarter than the rube utrecht a
satisfaction that only jebaited
encapsulates truly other emotes are
outdated and overrated the future is
debated okay what is it
what no this is just like that's a Conca
thing where you were like oh it's where
the camera was in focus on what my
thumbs why are you looking at me like
that oh no have I been cheated
you actually are a crouton so
orco stir cool Tola yeah well at least
at least the the sauce slides off of me
and doesn't get in all my holes like you
[Music]